okay so some background we're probably
all familiar with the idea of automatic
speech recognition or speech to text
this idea that you can talk into your
phone and then imagine aliy magically
takes the sound and converts it into the
words that you're saying and we've been
wanting to do this at least since we
figured out that you could convert sound
into pictures so that's what I'm showing
you some examples up here
these are spectrograms right so if
you've never seen this this is what it
looks like if you take some sound and
then you do some math to make a picture
out of it and sort of the state of the
art again is probably a lot of us know
for doing this is using neural networks
specifically a long short-term memory
Network some descendants of that family
of networks and just to give you a sense
of that so this graph here which is from
this this blog post which is really good
about the state of the art of speech
recognition and and will tweet up the
slides later by the way so this is word
error rate which is a very commonly used
metric in the field on the y-axis and on
the x-axis is time and you can see
because of the little oval that I made
that all those models at the end used by
directional LS TMS of one sort or
another so this long short-term memory
lsdm that's what it stands for that is a
recurrent connection and your neural
network which is supposed to capture
these dependencies across time right and
so you might think that if you can
capture long and short term dependencies
across time you would do a better job of
being able to go from speech to text
because you have all these different
levels of dependency across time in
speech okay but the stable-yard networks
that use LS TMS avoid segmentation what
do I mean by segmentation so so here's
this waveform this is from graves at
I'll 2005 this is a paper on connection
temporal classification which again
part of this family of these LS TM
networks that's that's their name for
their architecture in this paper but
what the figures showing at the top is
this waveform from sound this is three
words the sound of and you can see the
phonemes divided up by those dashed
lines and you could just have some
algorithm whatever it is could be like
supervised or like a support vector
machine some supervised learning
algorithm and it just classifies every
time frame in your sound and says this
is part of phoneme that or whatever and
when you do that you get implicit
segmentation right when when one phoneme
stops and another one starts in your
series of time bins then then you get a
segment but with this connection
connectionist temporal classification
and all these other LS TM models you
just map straight from your sound to
your words
so you neglect the segmenting of speech
you just go right from speech right from
sound to text and then and that's what
I'm showing here with these arrows right
so you don't have any idea of where one
word starts or stops you just go right
from here's my sound to here's my word
and you just pick the peak for whatever
probability you're looking at to decide
what word is what but there's a lot of
cases where you would care about the
segmentation right so if you're trying
to diagnose a speech disorder like
here's a spectrogram of stuttering you
know you want to be able to find the
links of the different speech segments
to try and diagnose how bad that
stuttering is or if you think about many
other speech disorders where we care
about something like the pitch of
someone's voice you can't really measure
the pitch accurately if you can't find
every segment likewise if you're trying
to figure out how the brain controls
speech it's hard to relate something
like muscle activity or brain activity
to speech if you can't figure out where
words start or stop and then last but
not least if you're thinking about these
models we have for automatic speech
recognition may
we don't know yet or at least there
hasn't been a lot of work done yet to
ask whether having some representation
of segments would help you do better on
recognizing speech with a lot of
background noise or with different
accents and again if you look at that
blog post that I link to at the
beginning it has a lot of some good
points about what these models have
issues with now okay so so stepping back
segmentation writ large is about finding
signal and noise right so so again it's
a lot of us probably know there's been a
ton of worked on object recognition so
can I find a bounding box for some
object in my image or can i segment the
image so that every pixel belongs to one
class or another in terms of time series
right you can try to find the piano keys
when they get played and some piece of
music or find in events and background
noise like footsteps or explosions and
then last but not least our favorite is
can you find elements of birdsong in a
spectrogram okay so so part of the
reason where we are happy to be giving
this talk is we want to propose this
idea that we might be able to use
birdsong as a sort of an EM mist for
benchmarking these segmentation
architectures right so so this is one
repository that our labs overlap is put
up but a lot of the labs in the songbird
field are working together to try to get
more of this data out there and let it
let me tell you a little bit we'll go
into like why we care about birdsong
so so we both working last where we
study them as a way to try to figure out
how the brain learns and controls speech
and similar motor skills so songbirds
you might not know learn their song in a
way that's very similar to how we learn
speech so they are taught it by a tutor
when they're juveniles and they acquire
during a sensitive period just like we
learn to talk you know from our parents
or whoever we grow up around and you can
learn more about the work that all these
different labs do if you go to songbird
science calm
and so what's what's kind of nice about
birdsong is that we you can segment it
into what we call syllables so I've been
talking about spectrograms but not
defining what a spectrogram is so just
to make sure we're all on the same page
on the y-axis of the picture on the top
and the lovely jet color scheme is
frequency and on the x-axis is time
right so so that's the spectrogram and
then what I'm showing you on the plot
below that is just the the amplitude of
the the birdsong and the way that we
find the segments typically is we just
look for crossings of the threshold of
the amplitude and that's what those
those red horizontal lines are so we
would just call those the segment's
those are our syllables and then we just
arbitrarily apply some labels to the
bird song and what's nice about the song
of many species is that it's pretty easy
to segment into these syllables you just
look for these brief silences that
separate the syllables and this is
easier than speech because you know in
speech are syllables all run together so
you know if you want to have this a hand
label data said something like Tim it
time it however you prefer to pronounce
that right that someone has to sit there
by hand and give their best guess about
one when we're one speech syllable
starts in another one stopped but song
can vary very much greatly between
species as much as phonemes and syntax
vary between languages so here's a zebra
finch song just one second of its song
they have a one motif that they'll just
sing over and over throughout their
adult life by comparison here's Begley's
finch song so they'll have one syllable
that we call branch points a few
syllables that will branch to two or
more syllables and this gives them a
sort of syntax to their song and then
last but not least Canaries which wish
yarn is working with Soho there's that
one second of zebra finch song down at
the bottom for comparative
a canary song can last 30 seconds to a
minute and it can have tens of different
types of syllables and they can repeat
those syllables for varying number of
times right so what's interesting about
this is by using the species the song of
different species we can see how well
these different models different neural
network architectures for example
generalize okay why do we care about
this so as an example use case from the
sobra lab we do these behavioral
experiments so this is a special Graham
again I'm showing you one syllable of
one bird song it'll sing as thousands of
times a day
we can target this with the computer and
real time each time it sings it sings
slightly different so that there's a
distribution of pitches for each
syllable and if we target part of that
distribution with the computer we can
play a blast of white noise whenever it
sings in that target a part of the
distribution and when we do that as I'm
showing you in cartoon form here
the pitch rapidly shifts up so the bird
doesn't like this white noise glass and
it can very rapidly adjust to avoid that
noise so this tells us that the birds
can still control their song as adults
once they finish learning which we we
didn't know about it so just a few years
ago yeah hello
and the uske sin in the garden lab is to
do with canary song so we record
Canaries and we not only record their
song which is like the spectrogram up
there but you also record neural signals
and we do that by implanting those mini
microscopes on this schedule you see
there it's basically a camera that can
look and see when there is any signal in
neurons and so to analyze this kind of
data song together with neural activity
what we're gonna do is relate the two so
it matters to be very very precise and
to be able to say exactly which syllable
is sung is every given moment and
segment them very precisely I'll show
you how this data looks when it's
attached no segment in song and and the
video that the camera sees but you'll
see it'll be quite a mess I mean but
what you'll see is a lot of flashing
cells in the video and in the bottom
left side you'll see the spectrogram
which is already out it is you will see
the repeating syllable and I will
highlight the syllable that's currently
being sung there's audio to that
it's not projected hope you can hear it
[Music]
it's a bit of a noise blasting sorry so
so but what I can do it and what we do
it's related the new activity and the
song and so just briefly example saying
that I can just pick up one of those or
two of those flashing cells and then in
the figures here show you two figures
for two cells and the signal is all
those traces are for multiple
repetitions of these songs all aligned
to time 0 which which is when the birds
start repeating this long syllable okay
very simple and just in this example you
can see the top cell I mean the color
coded for the traces is this for a
different type of syllabus so the black
ones are when the year long these long
syllables are being sung um and the
first old cell in the top prefers the
first syllable and the cell of the
bottom prefers the other two syllables
and this is the kind of findings will
look and find recently in the gamma lab
okay so so that's some use cases like
why do we care about being able to
segment and classify these syllables and
I you know again thinking about working
with songbirds they sing thousands of
songs a day so this is something we need
to automate you might ask well why can't
you just use some off-the-shelf machine
learning methods like like some some
algorithm like K nearest neighbors or
support vector machine and just classify
these segments cuz you just told me that
they're really easy to pick out of this
all and in fact I developed a librarian
that does that hybrid vocal classifier
so you can check that out the issue is
that these methods fail as soon as the
segmental fail
so if you have noise in the background
like those those white noise bursts that
I showed you or if you have a change in
the song because of the experiment or if
you're working with a species that has a
song that's not easily segmented like
the canary song so they can dramatically
change the volume of their song you know
they're like vocal gymnastics so so the
the automated segmentation that we
normally do fails when we're trying to
work with our songs so we need something
that does the segmentation for us some
some newer method and of course like the
answer to everything else it's neural
networks but then the question is which
neural network so so we have some very
preliminary results to show you to try
to get at this question we're comparing
neural network architectures and what we
need them to be able to do the output
should find the edges of the syllable so
in other words they should segment and
then they should label the syllables so
we want to get out of classification
just like the speech-to-text
networks do and as our training data
we're just taking these spectrograms and
showing it to the network and then as an
output we're getting for every time been
some label right so we get our our
implicit segmentation that way like like
I talked about before and so one way you
might think to do this one architecture
is a fully convolutional network and so
you know we don't have time to go into
the details in this I'm happy to talk
with people offline and I'm sure yarding
is too but just as a very high-level
fully convolutional network the input
again is a spectrogram the way that
these convolutions work as many of us
have probably seen before is you have
this layer made up of filters or kernels
that do the convolution they each kernel
contains a weight and the weights are
adjusted as the algorithm trains the
network and hopefully it learns to
represent some feature so you might
think of some feature in the syllable
that it would learn to recognize and
then you have some layer that hopefully
reduces the number of parameters like a
max pooling layer that takes the max
values across your kernel
and then hopefully you have this reduced
representation that's capturing whatever
is essential about the syllables and you
might spit out some classification likes
that syllable a or syllable v or
syllable C but what has been more
recently done is to instead return a
output that's the same size as the input
so this is a fully compositional network
and so now every point in your output is
a classification and so you can do this
with your spectrogram as well and then
then you can use some simple method like
some down the columns of your
spectrogram and just take the majority
vote and that would give you this
segmentation and so this is just a
picture of what that would look like
with spectrograms from this camera
okay neue paper just to give you some
idea to think they use like this sliding
window that moves across instead of
being fully convolutional but the the
output is the same and there's this
links to this actual paper and the code
at the end yeah a different approach is
or additional approach is to remember
that the spectrogram is not like just
like images the axis mean different
things or one is time and the other is
frequency so frequency is pretty much
like a spatial axis of the image and
indeed different syllables differ in
their fruit and frequency features and
using the same convolutional networks we
can maybe train filters to find those
features but time especially in
songbirds of speech you're out of time
serious datasets and has structure so we
have long and short-term and I'm hinting
to drag the rest the rest of it right
and coalition's in the data itself so
what we do and it indeed a train those
conclusion networks to pick up those
localized as spectral temporal features
but then we feed this into a recurrent
Network a an LST mo built an LST M that
hopefully or potentially can capture
those long and short duration
correlations the art of this layer can
then be projected on the different
labels for every time
and so the way that we're gonna compare
these architectures is we're going to
make a earning curve so this isn't a
learning curve and that's why it's in
quotes like you would you would normally
use to to check that your model is
actually learning what we care about
here is which model does the best given
the least amount of training data so for
for experimentalists you know we want to
label the least amount of songs and get
the best accuracy and then the way we're
gonna look at that is is a standard
approach where you're gonna take your
training data and and repeat it several
times so for each replicate we have this
training data set and we're going to
then look on a separate test set and see
what the accuracy is and so just grab
say say we're training it with 15
seconds of training data grab from our
bigger training data set five times 50
you know some number of songs that adds
up to 15 seconds and then take the
average across that number of songs and
the accuracy that we're looking at will
be frame wise accuracy so you could
think of other metrics something like a
word error rate you could have the
syllable error rate for a songbird but
for now we just want to look at how how
well does it classify every frame and
you know if it's doing pretty well at
that level then we might think that it's
also gonna be doing well if we look at
something like the syllable error rate
so here's the initial results and I
think what you'll notice is that there's
no clear difference so far so if
anything the the CNN bio STM is doing a
little better than the FCN so this is
this is using as as best as I could be
the same hyper parameters for each
network right so so you're seeing the
again the training set size is on the
x-axis and the accuracy is on the y-axis
and just looking at the average the the
error rate is lower for the CNN by LST M
but we can also ask what's how do the
parameters matter in this question and
in developing this algorithm I could
take more frequency bins or get better
frequency resolution to capture more
features of a of the canary then you
know other birds and spectrograms and it
also forces me to use more hidden layers
hidden units in the in the lsdm and and
then I can in this just example I
trained the network with 30 training
files on a bit of Bengal easy finch
songs this amounts to about 400 seconds
of data but then I held out you know the
grand majority of files about 900 files
to create test set distribution and what
I'm showing you here on the y-axis for
every file is the fraction of of error
in frame wise or bin once and this is
the distribution for the entire test set
and the median is about one point point
four percent per file and you can you
can ask okay this specific to this bird
or to this bird species well the
simplest case is to go back to the zebra
finches it just keeps singing the same
motif again again again so a bit of a
strong argument but again the
distribution here is only on the health
out data training the network on about
fourteen on fourteen files and testing
in about ten times that and the median
here is below billion of error bins
frettin of error bins per file is less
than one percent okay so you know I
think that again these are very initial
results and I think we're probably not
the first people to face this question
of doesn't matter if you have a
recurrent connection in your directed
acyclic graph or sorry you're all
network right so so you know especially
in this case where you're look you know
you have the whole sound right you
finished speaking and now you're trying
to segment it does it matter if your
network is recurrent so this is a bigger
question and I think you know as we
showed if you if you use a bunch of
hyper if you if you increase the number
of parameters as you adjust the hyper
parameters then you can get lower error
rates so so we're still working at this
we're
all our coding in the open so you can go
check it out Oh some other questions are
you know slight changes in the
architecture like this sliding window
idea that we told you about maybe if you
just have a big kernel that slides along
the whole spectrogram you can get the
segmentation out that way and we hope
again to to apply this not just to the
work that we're doing in our lab to a
segment song but that this might be
useful for people looking at things like
speech disorders or brain control of
speech and automatic speech recognition
possibly as well so we'd like to thank
our labs Gartner and sober lab and our
funding sources NIH NSF we both
benefited from the NVIDIA GPU grant
which made it possible for us to train a
bunch of these models and we will tweet
out the slides so you can go check out
our code on github we're happy to get
feedback from people I also want to
thank yard and this has been a really
great collaboration and he's really
pushed me and in all the ways that I
need it so and of course thanks to PI
did in New York City for inviting us hey
no question sure
yeah so so so we're the question is are
we trying to classify which bird is
singing a song so no in this case we do
know which bird species were working
with so when we when we train the
algorithms we're just trying to figure
out which syllable is being sung from
which specific bird so so it's a good
question which we very frequently get
right so but this isn't about
identifying species this is like is this
Begley's finch number one syllable a
right and and again going back to this
question of generalization what you can
look at I think working with birdsong is
does your model generalize across
individual one two three four five and
do so as well as some other model yeah
sure yeah so most of what we use in the
in the lab is is homespun but when it
comes to the analysis we're definitely
using the numpy sigh hi Matt I lived
Karis sense of uh we're sort of in the
process of putting stuff up a lot of it
is in the individual apps so what David
is I think leading a hirako and effort
to join all the song bailout and create
a joint source but every lab has their
own github the garden lab their own
github and a lot of the data massaging
and Isis and also capturing and homemade
code that we have is just out there yeah
so we're working on that but I yeah
other questions all right thanks
everybody for listening
[Applause]